hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
time for the monday morning podcast for
monday
um october 5th 2020 what's going on how
are you how's it going everybody
how was your beginning of the october
did you get some pumpkin spice
latte mocha [ __ ] whatever
i saw what you did i love the holiday
season and i just feel like
halloween is just it's so overlooked
you know i realize in the gay community
it's really celebrated but i don't know
that it's celebrated in a pumpkin spice
type of way
the crunch of the leaves under your feet
cinnamon sticks and your cereal
um yes the holiday season
everyone got [ __ ] why the hell would
you ask for a gift
oh it's not gonna stop the broads from
asking for something shiny right because
they're watching the kardashians with
all their who
wear right
oh jesus it's really funny like is it
funny bill well
let's let me present it and then you can
decide i think it's hilarious
that all of those high-end
brands the rodeo drive ones that like
now
when i look at that [ __ ] you know
what i i just equate that to a reality
show
star with ass fat in her lips
[Laughter]
this is a bulgaria [ __ ] purse oh
really
is that to carry all your ass fat over
to your [ __ ] plastic surgeon
you [ __ ] uh whatever it's the it's
the end of the world as
i know it and [ __ ] feel
fine um speaking of music if you could
call what i just did anything musical
i actually have this [ __ ] song in my
head
remember that song
like quincy jones dead
that dude compliment what she does
sandal roses just because
if it's violence she loves and let the
play
oh remember that song 5
100 ways i downloaded that album i
cannot get that song out of my head
i've been listening to it walking around
in new york city
i'm here this week and uh i've been
walking around just
makes me puts me in such a great mood
reminds me to be nice to my wife this
song
shouldn't have to remind you shut up
[ __ ] um
and it makes me feel it just puts me in
this stupid [ __ ] mood like that i'm
at the end of a feel-good movie
and uh it's helping me up because i'm
trying to work out this [ __ ] for this
gig i got this week
and i'm doing it in front of eight
people on top of a roof in the
in broad daylight with fire engines
driving by
out on sidewalks and everything but it's
amazing like i'm starting to uh
it's coming together just coming
together just keep working
i had my little hissy fit meltdown
because i had such a bad experience
doing stand-up here
you know last summer that the second i
saw the empire state building i was
triggered
well the reality is you can't even see
when you're out in jersey
all right underrated jersey
all right now i know that everybody
thinks jersey is just a bunch of animals
look there's a lot of animals there but
i mean there's a lot of animals out on
long island
you know a lot of [ __ ] animals in
massachusetts where i'm from there's a
lot of [ __ ] animals out there
a lot of [ __ ] animals okay but that's
good that's a good thing
it's a good thing that there's a bunch
of [ __ ] animals out there
because that's how you separate yourself
from the pack
you know it's okay i might not be the
smartest guy but you know
i stopped wiping my nose on my sleeve
when i was eight
so could i have a job
um dedicate her favorite song
and hold it closer all night long
love her today sorry
um oh i love her today five
100 ways
you know it's such an accurate song
that's how you should treat your woman
and like it's going to take at least 100
ways to try to keep her happy
sorry all right enough enough bill can
you just stop
it's a time to bring people together
during the new
normal um
hey do you think dopey's gonna wear a
[ __ ] mask now
[Laughter]
oops that's like when you're saying
there's no [ __ ] way
the miami heat are going to win a game
against the lakers they're going to
sweep
them but bob oops this guy this guy is a
mask on he's uh he's he's standing like
200 feet away from people and you get
[ __ ] covet and
you know what's hilarious is i love how
he [ __ ]
he goes uh he try to make himself
patriotic
well that's because so and so had it and
she's a troop and me and melanie we love
her we're hugging her we're kissing her
i tried to get a threesome going
she sneezed on my [ __ ] if my [ __ ] was
inhaling unlike clinton i always inhale
he never inhales
uh some people say i'm the greatest
inhaler ever and the kovid went in
through
my [ __ ] as long as my tie very long tie
very long [ __ ]
satisfies melanie satisfies her 100 ways
um
whatever i would i just hope that people
who who have been duped into thinking
that this virus
is somehow political uh now that he
has tested positive a bunch of leaders
are all coming out now around the world
all right all right i kissed too many
babies or whatever the [ __ ] they're
saying they did
on the campaign trail um
not like everybody has it um okay that's
everybody that's everybody bobby bowden
90 years old he has fortunately has mild
symptoms so uh you know i don't want to
see the president die so hopefully he
gets better
um and also
you know i don't know comedically just
the guy's just
so many jokes
um anyway let's let's let's plow ahead
here let's let's get out of that [ __ ]
he's going to be fine his wife is like
30 years old so she'll be fine
and oh slight dig that bill um
everybody'll be fine just
try to wear a mask of people i mean and
it's not just the people
in the red states not you know the
people out there on their [ __ ] boats
the bass boats the only guy i got twin
uh
350 [ __ ] buick engine i took out of
my [ __ ] uh
uh what was that [ __ ] car my neighbor
had
he was asleep you know says hello to my
wife in a way i don't appreciate so when
he's asleep i went over to his buick
regal
he dropped to 350 and i took it out put
my baby um
it's not just those people because i'm
walking around liberal ass new york and
just the amount of people that are
uh you know they yank their mask down
because they're gonna talk on their
[ __ ] cell phone
you know and then they're standing next
to you and like as you're waiting to
cross the street it's like you're
breathing on me
you're in my [ __ ] airspace here um
you know people with
the mask on top of their head below the
chin below the nose all of that [ __ ]
it's still going it's going on
everywhere
and there's a couple of breakouts here
in liberal [ __ ] new york so i'm not
[ __ ] on the red states i'm trying to
bring everybody together
uh you're only as strong as the dumbest
person in your state don't ever forget
that so let's root for the scientists
they've got to come up with a cure
because we're too [ __ ] dumb
we're too [ __ ] dumb to literally just
do what they tell us to do
um i literally think that there was a
[ __ ] meteor that you could see or an
asteroid
that was going to destroy the [ __ ]
earth unless you did x y
and z there would still be people on the
internet with no scientific background
going live
you know i actually i don't think that's
all fake it's a fake rock you can see
look
around the ridges uh they took that out
of e.t
or some [ __ ] sci-fi i don't watch
sci-fi um
but whatever that's it is it is what it
is and every day
these [ __ ] dopes go out there
religious people
you know your little group uh because
god loves you best you're not gonna wear
it
you got a boat you want to show up your
[ __ ] tank tan line whatever [ __ ] it
is whatever it is you're doing
talking on your [ __ ] phone whatever
the [ __ ] it is you know
as much as you're doing that the god
bless these scientists and the doctors
treating people and and the people
trying to figure this thing out so we
could all try to get back to work
for the holiday season what do you think
is going to happen this holiday season
people were hit hard
economically i don't think that
anybody's going to be out in the stores
well i actually think that uh you know a
lot of people
uh you know we're finding that they're
out in the store i saw a
story the other day it showed
saying that people were actually out in
stores shopping and they went to fifth
avenue
in all the the whoreware stores um
and it's like yeah those people are rich
right of course they're out
they've been out they're not ultra rich
because when you're ultra rich what i
learned
is that you you have a a open credit
card account
at the store like a scalper remember
back in the day
ac dc tickets you're first in lines at
strawberries records and tapes
you [ __ ] buy it they went on sales at
nine you get it at 901 and you're like
first row mezzanine it's like what the
[ __ ]
how do they get all that [ __ ] yet
because there's there's always
somebody that has an inside angle right
so at these whoreware stores
there's always going to be somebody that
uh has an open account
you know they get the celebs to wear
them first
you know something bouncing off their
butt cheeks as they're walking down the
street
talking about their clam whatever the
[ __ ] it is they're doing nowadays
you know and uh you know some dj's got
it on or some [ __ ] by the way did
what who dies more djs are [ __ ]
comedians
every time i turn around if a comedian
doesn't die a dj dies if a dj doesn't
die a [ __ ] comic dies
are we all [ __ ] eating in the same
green rooms around the country
um anyways let's get back to the horror
um oh my god did you see the balenciaga
[ __ ]
line for the fall uh no i didn't i did
not see it
i don't watch the real housewives where
they have a [ __ ]
you know a stripper pole next to their
pizza oven in their [ __ ] kitchen
all bedazzled this is a rose gold
pole i took a stripper dance
class
my husband likes to see me do standing
splits
while he eats beef ragu [ __ ] ravioli
i had that the other day man
ragoon ravioli are two different things
i think i had the rav i don't know what
the [ __ ] it was it was
dressed the pasta was dressed
with wild boar i believe and um
i gotta tell you i i was really amazed
at that
the fact that i was eating a wild boar
that i didn't have to kill
i didn't have to go into the woods and
feel my heart rate going this is
a boar that is wild like the salmon
right and you don't know what it's gonna
do
it's got them tusks i know enough that
i've seen wild boars
in in uh
on youtube and i've watched lions
and hyenas and all these [ __ ] people
animals whatever you call them
take these things down and they never
want to be on the business end of the
pig
you know the second the pig [ __ ] the
boar whatever you call it the [ __ ]
turns around and runs at him they're
like hey you know i know i'm the king of
the beast but i'm not trying to [ __ ]
blow out an acl with those tusks
whatever the [ __ ] it's gonna do and they
get they get out of the way
every once in a while there's a couple
of them when you just got the jordan
the alpha males alpha male of
uh [ __ ]
wild boars or whatever and they actually
chase the lines off
there's not a lot of those videos
because usually what happens is they
freak out
and then they start running and then
they're [ __ ] because the lion can run
faster
they sweep the leg like cobra kai and
then that's it they just [ __ ] grab
them and it's over
it's not over there's a lot of squealing
involved why am i talking about this i
don't know because it was it was
delicious
and i've been old billy elliptical the
last couple of days to make sure i get
my girlish figure in shape here
for my new york gigs and um
that's what i've been up to but i've
been uh busting my ass here
i gotta do something on tv this weekend
i [ __ ] gotta you know not talk the
way i talk on the podcast so i've been
working it out
doing stand-up and all of these crazy
places it's like when i first moved to
new york
and it's even even beyond that because
at least i was inside
well a lot of sidewalk gigs uh
rooftops and [ __ ] like that in front of
like you know four or five people
because
you got to stay within the guidelines of
uh
the colvid protocol so um
it's definitely been interesting but
it's always fun to be back here and
stuff i actually saw a steakhouse
i think i'm gonna go to after i get past
this [ __ ] um
that i've never heard of before provided
my wife wants to go there
and uh yeah that's it that's pretty much
it so i've been doing that and i didn't
have time to watch any of the nfl what
papa
um but i did catch the scores
and uh i got a question for you guys as
a patriots fan
are the buffalo bit your buffalo bills
are four and oh
123 points for a hundred points against
uh you know i'd like to see that number
a little lower as a
uh non-coach at any level in my life
um the day seems great and this seems
like uh
i don't know i don't think that they're
gonna have difficulty uh
winning the division um because i feel
like now
obviously if they keep winning in the
situation that we're in
with cam newton testing positive i mean
it happens it happens there's 40
something guys there when you look like
a movie star and a superhero people want
to be around you
you know you're showing up wearing a
canary yellow [ __ ] suit that doesn't
quite reach your calves
i mean this is a guy that's going to be
around town
you just some people just have that
they have that thing you know someone
like me i'm a [ __ ] you know
me i'm a six on a good day i always
stood in the corner at a party
you don't got to worry about me right
you don't gotta worry i mean who knows
i'm walking around new york so god knows
i could catch this [ __ ] too but i really
think
you know there's a reason why magic got
sick and larry bird didn't back in the
day you know what i mean there just is
just some people
people want to be around other people
have that a why don't you [ __ ] leave
me alone vibe
so uh we're gonna try to fight through
this they've rescheduled the game with
uh we playing kansas city
kansas city i guess a couple people on
their team i mean i don't know
i don't know what's going on i feel like
they all [ __ ] jump in a hot tub at
the end of the game
bring some [ __ ] in there i mean you
know you know if you're a [ __ ] you're
not [ __ ] wearing a mask
um you're wearing glasses
sorry that was a bad joke all right um
where am i going here wow that just
reminded i've not watched porn
i'm like done it's gone out of my life i
haven't watched it since may
it's it's it's it's it's gone like booze
i was talking to somebody the other day
i said hey man i've always been like two
years without a drink and i don't know
what happened
in the i thought about it for a year and
a half and somewhere in the last six
months
it just went away and my buddy was just
like yeah because he's been sober like
seven years
and he's like yeah it's amazing how it
was such a big part of your life and
then it just kind of
one day just off in the wind it's gone
so um happy about those those two things
that i've done
there's other areas of my life obviously
i need to work on and if i forget those
areas i'm sure uh the woman in my life
will remind me
uh your chiefs are three and oh let's
look around the league what do we got
going on this is very exciting i love
that nfl football is here a couple of
co-vid tests
doesn't [ __ ] scare me why doesn't
scary bill because i don't play in a
football team
steelers three a very quiet three-and-oh
um the browns your cleveland browns
three in one scoring all kinds of
[ __ ] points
and letting up all kinds of points 124
points for
126 against your cincinnati bengals with
joe
burrow huh i guess the first rookie
quarterback ever to throw 300 yards per
game
uh in his first three games isn't that
amazing i'll tell you right now little
one or two things nobody wants to play
titans at 3-0 they're a close team right
they got the kovid too
i guess the [ __ ] bears blew it
against the colts
judging by some of the tweets i saw um
texans oh and four no defense
i'm judging this all on just what points
four points against i
i missed a lot of the games the last
couple of weeks doing all the [ __ ]
that i've been doing
so um
i don't know wait let me check out the
nfc
let's see we got the woeful woeful jesus
[ __ ] christ can you win a [ __ ]
game
nfc east this is how bad they are the
new york giants are 0 and 4
and they're only one game out of first
place like they're a game and a half
because the eagles are one two one one
uh
the team that plays in washington one in
three cowboys one and three
i mean it's just i i watched a bit of
the giants game right
and this is like the worst time to be in
new york city is when the giants and the
jets suck
because your nfl sunday is gonna be the
worst
because first of all you're gonna get
announcers you've never heard from
who may someday be the next guys but or
or ladies whatever right
but they stink it's like hey um
joe blow and this is freddy who the [ __ ]
are you and we are here
live at giant stadium and they're about
ready to lose by 20 points i saw
something when i watched
first of all how [ __ ] up is it that
new york city has two football teams
that are a combined 0.8 they have twice
as many
at bats to win a game to win a super
bowl
and they're both oh and [ __ ] eight
it's unbelievable
it really is the new york new york new
york yankees if i can get it out
once again saving the city how many
times do the yankees have to put on the
[ __ ]
superhero cape and make this
this a respectable sports city with your
two baseball two football
two basketball two [ __ ] hockey
unbelievable although the islanders did
well this year
you know they lost to the eventual
stanley cup champions
in the eastern conference files um
seahawks four and oh they look [ __ ]
good they
look good um packers three you know
um and then well you can't you can't
ignore tom terrific
tom terrific 3-0 he's got the tampa bay
buccaneers
tampa bay tampa i live on a houseboat so
i can't pay so i won't pay taxes
uh [ __ ] buccaneers he's got him three
and one
i don't i wish i saw that game yesterday
um like i said i'm just working on this
[ __ ] thing i got to do
and um i guess they scored like three
touchdowns late it was just classic tom
brady i saw gronk had a great catch
i am um this is such a fun year
you know i hate that tom ended up having
to leave the patriots for whatever
reason but like to watch this guy
still be great and the chance of him
leading a completely different team
to a super bowl championship like i
think if he does this
first of all who the [ __ ] gonna get
six rings again
you gotta have somebody with tom skill
his [ __ ] insane drive
and then pair him up with the next bill
belichick
i mean i think those players come along
but the the
the odds of them getting together i
would compare that to like lead singers
and guitarists
there's some amazing lead guitarists
and bands that just had a [ __ ] front man
and other guitarists will bring them up
and be like oh man this [ __ ] guy was
just you know
like you know i always say that about
and i'm not saying like anybody is any i
don't name the [ __ ] bands but there's
a few bands but they just had a killer
guitarist
and then they just had some high pitch
[ __ ]
i don't know i don't know what singing
about what you're [ __ ] robots and
[ __ ] and you're just like okay whatever
um it's the equivalent of being a great
[ __ ] quarterback and getting drafted
by the lions back in the day or the
bears when they suck to the browns for
all those years
it's a very difficult it's very rare
that the bill walsh
the joe montana somehow get together the
mick
and keith of football get together so
um but anyway getting back to what i'm
saying if he [ __ ] goes down
tampa bill he's already gone down there
if he [ __ ] wins down there
gets ring number seven
um even if somebody in the future gets
seven seven
he's still gonna have the yeah but i
went to another team
and did it there too i left
mick jagger started my own band
and it was just as big as my last band i
mean that would be
amazing but um anyway so we shall see
i'm excited about that thursday night
football game too
speaking of tom brady tom brady and nick
foles meeting again i believe for the
first time
since the eagles beat the patriots in
the super bowl in that super bowl that i
still maintain
nobody who played on defense during that
game should have got a ring
she got half a ring
[Laughter]
and i hope the punters took some sort of
selfie there so we knew that they were
at that game what a [ __ ] weird game
that was
um so anyway plowing ahead here
uh i've been having a great time in new
york as i mentioned
and uh just seeing like just i just miss
walking around new york
because it's starting to get a little
edgy here you know all the people with
money everybody [ __ ] left
and then you know or leaving or whatever
and uh so it's a little sketchy areas
are a little sketchy
walk through washington square park
something i would never do
when i first moved here and then after a
while it became like [ __ ]
you know mayberry and then last night we
were there we were walking through
me and my lovely wife and a friend and
then uh
it was just sort of weird sketchy [ __ ]
going on these people
with some boxes that look like retail
that they were opening and sort of
throwing around and
it's like what the [ __ ] is going on
there remind me that old
that old thing back in the day i ran
into a comic
roughly my age right and we were talking
about all the old scams
[Music]
that they used to have and they used to
be this one scam back in the day
where those empty boxes they would find
these empty vcr boxes
and they'd stick like a brick in there
and then they would tape them up
all right and then they'd go yeah yeah
you want you want to buy vcr you'll go
okay
it's all good you know he hands you the
buck you give money hands you the box he
takes off and you bring it all the way
home and you open it up and there's a
[ __ ] brick in there
there's another one right now where uh
somebody pulls up and asks you if you
want to buy a iphone
so you go okay and then you know
you hand him the money as he hands you
the phone
and he's sitting in his car right and
then you go oh i
what's the thing to unlock it and the
guy let me unlock it for you and then
you hand it back to him and he just
drives away
[Laughter]
there's that one there's another one you
have unprotected sex
like an idiot and uh then the [ __ ]
chick like a month later says she's
pregnant she wants to abort it
and she get whatever the running cost of
that you pay her she's not pregnant and
she takes that money
that's just what's going on out there
people it's a crate 2020 is a crazy time
just giving you i don't think anybody's
gonna do the vcr scam anymore
but uh those other ones those are those
are the new ones
those are the phone one and the uh um
pregnant one um yeah but people do what
they got to do they do what they got to
do
um so i was walking down i've been
walking a lot in new york because for
some stupid reason i'm like well i want
to get on the subway with covid i got to
stay [ __ ] healthy here
um but then i'm walking down the street
like i said people have their masks down
you know down
talking and you know construction
workers you know those [ __ ] guys
it's over there you know how hard
they're working they can't have that
[ __ ] thing over their face
i think i would think or whatever
they're just all around each other i
don't know if they don't they don't give
a [ __ ]
um so if you go into a deli during lunch
time they all come walking in
um but anyway i'm still walking down the
street and
uh i was one okay so i'm going down i
think i was on like
fifth avenue or something in the 20s and
i see this guy
and he puts up his fist to fist-bump me
and i'm like what the [ __ ] i wasn't
really thinking and i'm like i had my
headphones on listen to music i was like
oh maybe uh
he's seen my comedy or something so as
i'm reaching up to give him a fist bump
i get closer and i realize that he has
no fingers
he just has like a palm and he's holding
up to show me that he has no fingers so
maybe i'll give him money and now my
fist is already up there to fist bump
uh his balled up palm and i had to kind
of play that off
and then i saw this really tall chick
with
huge tits walking towards me
and her tits were out too you know big
ass crack right down the front and
my first thought was oh that's got to be
a dude
right you know if she was shorter i
would say that's a woman and those tits
are fake
you know because usually when a woman
has huge tits she's so sick of guys
commenting on them and ogling them she
wears like nine sports bras and tries to
get to work without something hey nice
[ __ ]
rack hey tell your dad i said nice work
you know that dumb [ __ ]
but when they're walking around and they
got them out i always think they're
either fake and if they're tall i think
that it's a dude
and she came by and it wasn't it was a
woman so that's what i learned about
myself
a tall woman with her tits out i i
immediately think that's that's a dude
i know what you're doing you're trying
to get me not to look at your face so i
see your strong jaw i don't see your
strong jaw
um anyway i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm
talking about i'm just babbling here
just babbling here killing time all
right let's uh let's do some reads here
for the week oh look who it is everybody
helix alex
uh not able to sleep because of work
stress he looks sleep makes personalized
mattresses
made right here in the united states of
america and ships straight to your doula
with free no contact delivery get away
from me
free returns and a hundred night sleep
trial gross
uh to choose a mattress helix helix made
a quiz
that takes just two minutes to complete
unless you're a dope it'll take you two
and a half
and matches your body type and sleep
preference to the perfect mattress for
you
if you like a mattress that's really
soft or
firm you sleep on your side or on your
back
or on your stomach or you sleep really
hard i hate that
i hate that line you sleep hot can you
imagine
that's a deal bro i'm out [ __ ]
sleeping next to some
furnace some clammy chick uh with helix
there's a specific mattress for each and
everybody's unique taste
take the quiz and get matched for the
type of sleeper you are
i love helix evidently but you don't
need to take my word for it
helix was awarded the number one best
overall mattress of 2020 by gq
wired magazine and this is what puts me
over the top apartment therapy
okay that's what they do they do
apartments what's one of the biggest
places where are you going to spend the
most time in your apartment
the bedroom you're not going to spend
eight hours in the living room unless
you're a gamer
uh let's let's just go uh just go to
helixsleep.com
take their two-minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life
they have a 10-year warranty and you get
to try it out for a hundred nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up
and give you a full
real full refund if you don't love it
but you will
right now helix is offering up to 200
off mattress orders for our listeners
get up to 200
off at healingsleet.com you know what
you can do to a mattress in a hundred
nights
what if you're a bed wetter oh my god i
can't imagine
some of the stories those guys have who
have to pick up those mattresses
dude i don't know if he killed somebody
or [ __ ] some chick on the rag but i'll
tell you right now
i got to get a new job i don't mind
delivering them
it's the picking them up all right here
we go here we go here we go oh hey
look who it is everybody my bookie how
the [ __ ] you doing ah everybody's a
winner get over here you get the [ __ ]
outta here
all right i love mondays and sundays uh
and i love thursdays you know why two
words nfl action
um i'm just supposed to say i love
mondays and sundays you know i think
every day is special
but i love mondays and sundays you know
why two words nfl action
i love sundays almost as much as brady
used to love
sundays in new england but now he's in
tampa
uh we're the only thing he's got to be
excited about is that florida sunshine
and the fact that they're 3-0
in first place in their division i'll
tell you what though
my book you got this whole online
betting thing figured out you sign up
you make a deposit and they'll match you
dollar for dollar
so you get some extra cash to play with
plus they got all kinds of cash prizes
contests and free bets
tuned in late didn't place your bet in
time don't even sweat it
because they let you bet the game's live
so you can uh
analyze [ __ ] it we'll do it live so you
can analyze the game and make your picks
if nothing else you gotta check out the
website
uh you gotta check out the website
because they had they got a hundred
thousand dollar
super contest and it runs the entire nfl
season
pick five games five games against the
spread each week
score the most points by the end of the
season and you know what you're going to
walk away with 25 000 bucks
but that's not it every four weeks the
player with the top scorer wins five
grand
five g's everybody uh my bookie is
giving
uh giving it away if you trust your
intuition
you can make a lot of money and have a
lot of fun
i think you need a little more than
intuition i just i don't know there's
just something about that team
sign up with my bookie today and get
your deposit matched all the way up to 1
000 bucks
it's the easiest money you've ever made
in your life all you got to do
to claim the uh all you got to do to
claim the deposit
bonus is use the promo code burr b-u-r-r
winning season is finally here
and it's only at my bookie now get the
[ __ ] outta here
oh look who it is me undies why don't
you wear a master do do do me undies me
undies it's too difficult to
task i don't like the way it feels
the rubs on my nose and then i squeal
so i get the covet and i breathe on my
ants
and now she's [ __ ] in the [ __ ] bed
but helix will pick it up
all right me undies everybody my undies
believes that comfort
is about more than what's touching your
skin
it's about feeling comfortable in your
skin why don't you learn to accept you
uh keyword your y-o-u-r not someone
else's
this isn't a michael myers movie
uh oh that's a bad reference
comfortable in your skin not someone
else this should be this isn't a
hannibal lecter movie he's the one to
put the face on his head
right he put a face on his face that's
like joe crum a hat on a hat
uh but it is almost halloween uh which
means you can now match your undies to
the spookiest season of all time the
undies just launched three
new halloween prints so whether you're
into cats
the musical or the oh the animals blood
or skeletons
they've got something right up your
haunted alley now why would you say
right up your alley when you're talking
about undies now i'm thinking of
somebody with a wedgie
with the middle of the cat i can see the
cat head on one butt cheek the tail on
the other and the body's getting sucked
in
like some sicko with the vacuums trying
to kill it well that's part of the
scariest part of
halloween all right their undies grow on
trees no seriously
i'm not i'm not bullshitting you they're
made from irresistibly soft
natural fibers sourced from beechwood
trees
and you know what natural fibers means
uh that their micro modal modal
is not only super soft but breathable
light
and impossibly cozy that's some serious
comfort
everything meundies does is to help you
feel truly comfortable from head to toe
uh from outside to in never run out of
me of undies with me
with the md's membership a subscription
that sends
new pairs right to your door because who
really wants to grab that questionable
six-pack of underwear at your local
drugstore
plus get site-wide savings and exclusive
sales yeah you can't get the underwear
at the drugstore you got some cats
sleeping on it
uh my undies had a great off my undies
has a great offer for my listeners for
first time
any first-time purchasers you can get 15
percent off in free shipping myani's
also has their problem-free philosophy
if you're not satisfied with any of
their products for any reason
they'll refund or exchange it no caveats
no question
to get 15 off your first order and free
shipping go to meundies.com that's
meundies.com
all right lastly but not leastly we have
hymns
it wasn't us it was them the warriors
um men have tried all kinds of odd
unusual solutions to treat
erectile dysfunction example
snake oil pills herbs or herbs as they
say in england
hypnotism but hymns offers solutions
grounded in real medical science for
hims.com
is all about men's wellness need help
with erectile dysfunction
hair loss hey or have a cold
uh interested in mental health or covid
19 home test
hymns is for you wow they added a whole
other dynamic to it
i can take a home test to find out if
i'm out of my [ __ ] mind that's
amazing
uh through hymns you get the
prescription medication that treats
erectile dysfunction
uh real science real solutions to
hymns makes it easy hymns connects you
with a licensed
medical professional online who can
prescribe fda
approved prescription medication to
treat erectile dysfunction
um
you get the same active ingredient as
that expensive little pill
but without the expensive price tag ah
they got the knockoff stuff i love it
for free
oh not for free but for less money uh
this could cost hundreds of bucks if you
had to go through a doctor or pharmacy
now with hymns hymns makes it simple and
affordable
no embarrassing conversations no
expensive appointments just answer a few
questions online about your medical
history and provide and a provider will
confidently review
um no one reviews it more confidently
than me
um if approved your medic your
medication is shipped directly to your
door in a discreet
package and shipping is free no more
searching online for answers to
questions about
erectile dysfunction or sexual wellness
just go to just go to your hymns account
and ask a medical professional uh you
can trust
why live with erectile dysfunction
when the solution can be so simple try
hymns today by starting out with a free
online visit
go to for hims.com for your free visit
uh that's for hims.com burr bird
b-u-r-r-e-d i'm sorry
for hims.com b-u-r-r-e-d
bird it looks like bur red um for hims f
o r
h i m s dot com slash bird b
u r r e d disclaimer
must include okay prescription products
are subject to medical provider approval
and require an online consultation with
the medical provider who will determine
if a prescription is appropriate
see website for full details and safety
information
remember that's for hims.com bird
b-u-r-r-e-d okay
back to the podcast baby
back to the broadcast lady all right
let's get into some of the reads here
all right helicopter warf warefare
in vietnam and did you mean like warfare
it says w-a-r-e what is warefare
uh hey oh billy rednuts i just wanted to
recommend that you listen to
episode 248 of jocko
willink's podcast with john stryker
meyer
where uh they discuss operation tailwind
of the vietnam war in the great deep in
great detail
from the point of view of the soldiers
who survived this operation
well i'm already in helicopters were
beginning to play huge roles in warfare
strategy during the time
and were used to carry soldiers deep
behind enemy lines during the vietnam
war
the soldiers oh sorry the stories they
share are absolutely insane in this
podcast
they talk about what it was like to fly
with the pilots who would fly in and out
of the jungle to rescue soldiers
while being shot at yeah
um there's a comic i know tom rhodes his
dad flew a helicopter in vietnam and i
smoked a cigar with him one time and he
told me
some absolutely insane stories um anyway
and while the helicopter flying in front
of them
okay wait i gotta i told that tom rhodes
thing in the middle of a sentence let me
back up here
they talk about what it's like to fly
with pilots who would fly in and out of
the jungle to rescue soldiers while
being shot at
and while the helicopters flying in
front of them are getting shot down
dude the balls of that crazy stories
about dealing with engine failure from
enemy fire handling auto rotations with
a full load of wounded soldiers yeah
you're probably loaded beyond
what you could carry in some instances
and surviving cr
crash landings uh i know you're a nerd
when it comes to helicopters
guilty as charged i know you would
appreciate the skills of these military
helicopter
pilots even more than someone who knows
nothing about helicopters warning though
some of the stories are very graphic uh
hope you and your family are doing well
in this new normal
uh and go [ __ ] yourself um
thank you man i really appreciate that
that's amazing i i will definitely
uh i will definitely check that out
um i actually ran into a a guy that flew
helicopters and um i think he flew him
in the middle east
i was like wow that's cool you know now
that you're out do you you know you got
a pilot you know you still fly or
whatever and he goes nah
he was like the i kind of lost my
thrill for when she gets once you get
shot at when you're up there
you kind of like being down here
[Laughter]
all right oh and last week i was talking
about the seahawks forever i've been
trying to find a picture of a seahawk i
could never find one and uh then i saw
someone on bar stool sports saying
they're not a real animal
and uh but then a bunch of people
including this person reached out said
seahawks
and i'm talking about the seattle
seahawks here and now we're talking
about the bird here seahawks are another
name
for uh an osprey o-s-p-r-e-y i don't
know let's let's let's find out how to
say that
so the next time i'm at a cocktail party
and they bring up nfl football
it could be the seattle seahawks you
know that's actually just another name
for an
osprey and then they'll go okay douche
all right how do you say this oh wait
osprey oh osprey
it's an osprey seahawks are nothing
seahawks are another name for osprey
uh hey billy hey billy bird boy
my apology if i'm the 30th bird nerd to
email you what a seahawk is uh
yeah yeah you're that's about right
about 30 people but i heard you bitching
about mascots on sept
the september 28 podcast and needed to
weigh in
most of the times i'm not bitching
that's i just have that tone in my voice
uh an osprey is the bird that the
seattle seahawks are named for
the seattle osprey i can see why they
chose seahawks
seahawks seattle seahawks cc um
so you see radar um seahawks are just
the common name for them
they mainly hunt fish and have evolved
for this purpose
i gotta tell you they're a good-looking
bird especially for a hawk they usually
look like really pissed
this one just looks like uh i don't know
annoyed but like kind of self-satisfied
maybe just eight
um that's good to know
because there are there are a number of
things you know remember for the longest
because you couldn't look that [ __ ] up
when you were a kid
like i remember as a kid and i was
watching um len bias
great lent bias rest his soul when he
was playing from
maryland and they were the the terrapins
and i was like what the [ __ ] is a
terrapin you'd have to go all the way
down to the goddamn library
you know instead of just reaching down
with your cancer cars and phone which is
right next to your balls and looking up
what is a terrapin you know and then you
can just wait for someone to ask
what is a terrapin after you just looked
it up it's a turtle
what are you a [ __ ] [ __ ] you didn't
look it up with your thumb
in your pocket hmm sorry
very dehydrated i've been doing the
elliptical all week uh
the blip the political uh forest
cleaning
uh dear bill sucks i have to say this
but this is not a political email i
don't care who the hell
you or anyone votes for hey there's
somebody enlightened forest maintenance
is a large part of fire prevention
i volunteered in high schools with the
same attitude
this is pointless why the [ __ ] are we
cleaning the forest
i just wanted to get outside to meet my
required hours to graduate so i did it
anyways
i learned a lot and it definitely
changed my perspective about what it
means to maintain the parks and how
important it is
for a lot of different reasons dead
brush is what causes
fires to spread 10 times faster than it
normally would
i understand that but like in and around
la they do that
there's always crews of people cutting
that [ __ ] down
trying to do the best they can okay this
isn't
it isn't just like these fires have
always happened out here
so the fires are not you know
um out of the ordinary but like
with the planet heating up
which the scientists tell me is
happening so i listened to them
we had the worst fires we've ever had
um i understand that you need to do this
stuff i'll continue here
um it makes the fire really less
rely less on the wind to spread um
the the dangerous cycles in california
of extremely healthy conditions turning
to dead
and dry is the largest factor
um i thought it was because we had
humidity this year they were talking
about we had all this humidity now
like weather has literally changed since
i've been in [ __ ] l.a in 2007.
used to be a dry heat you'd go outside
and you felt like there was a god had a
magnifying glass he was between you and
the sun and he was trying to burn the
top of your head
but it wasn't like that east coast uh
humid [ __ ] weather and now we have
that we have [ __ ] mosquitoes and [ __ ]
it's really weird although i did hear
the mosquitoes came over on some
freightliner from [ __ ] i don't know
somewhere in south pacific who knows
anyways the majority of the fires
started are man-made
and within relative distance to man-made
trails and campsites um
i don't know i i was hearing that
because
the the weather conditions there was a
lot of lightning
that starts at every [ __ ] year i know
there was the gender neutral [ __ ]
or the general reveal thing anyway it is
the responsibility of the state to
offset these man-made factors
i won't [ __ ] about power lines and
translators uh transistors cause
wait i won't [ __ ] about power lines
and transistors because i didn't
have to deal with that so i won't start
blaming power companies
i guess what i'm saying is that we
actually do need to clean our force
in a methodical way if we want to help
slow the spread i agree with that
but we also should probably look to
different cleaner energy
you know um i would go nuclear if you
didn't have to bury that [ __ ] in the
ground for [ __ ] 9 000 years um
i would we should embrace the sun and
see how that works i would go solar
because no matter what we do we're going
to leave some sort of carbon footprint
so
that one seems to be the least like i
said just take all the old blue bloods
and say hey
you can't do oil anymore but now you own
the sun so you still have us all by the
balls right isn't that great
and uh anyway and you get all the money
from the solar [ __ ] okay
is that okay can we do this now do you
care about children anymore
all right this is obviously could never
prevent them all but when it comes to
defending homes it makes a difference
i i listen i agree with
with all of that okay but um that needs
to be done
and then also we need to find a
we need to find cleaner ways to live we
need to recycle all this [ __ ] we we need
to do that we know we need to do and
we've been putting it off like a term
paper
i think we should do that is my point
okay i hope these electric cars help
um i hope there's cleaner ways for
airplanes to fly i just
hope all of that [ __ ] we just sort of
lessen the pollution that we're putting
in there that
from what the scientists are saying is
heating up the planet and causing
the normal california fire fires to be
even crazier
and uh i don't know and if you're just
sitting there going well i don't live in
california so i don't give a [ __ ]
california is is letting you know what
is coming
for the rest of the states eventually if
we keep doing what the [ __ ] we're doing
according to scientists
so um
i don't know so and then i know people
are going to be like well you know i can
find
just as much uh scientific proof on the
other side that
suggests something completely different
it's just like yeah at the end of the
day you're not a scientist
and neither am i so i just choose to
listen to the
you know the accepted ones that the
government tell me those those are the
ones telling me i don't i don't know
well
maybe with global warming that's like a
political thing too i don't
whatever i'll just shut up why don't i
just stick with comedy all right cancel
culture [ __ ] of the 60s
oh this is interesting uh what's up
billy red rocks
under a blood red pubes there uh i was
watching
an episode of the twilight zone that
aired in the 1960s that made me think
about modern day cancel culture
um it was about the creepy looking dude
who wanted various random people fired
because he just knew they were
communists yeah that was the uh
they were probably doing an episode on
the red scare
um you know
i would think that that's what the
mccarthyism anyway this dude
wanted these people canceled more than
someone who didn't receive
wait this dude one of these people
canceled more
than someone who didn't receive direct
eye contract
from ellen hey look at that ellen
degeneres joe uh
with absolutely no evidence uh it's sad
but i feel like
if canceled culture existed 60 years ago
it will never go away what are your
thoughts
um i i it ebbs and flows they're always
trying to get
rid of people various ways shame them
shoot them uh you know discredit them
slander them there's always just all
kinds of ways that they yeah they're
always trying to do that i would agree
with that but i i
think in the past though it was people
in power
um we're trying to do it where now
it's just sort of i guess they do have a
power with social media
um it's really a crazy time
but yeah it's something human beings do
anyway
let me finish reading this glad to hear
you've been staying safe and not buying
into the sea breeze preventing covert
[ __ ]
i've been working as a delivery driver
throughout this entire pandemic
congratulations you kept your job man
that's a big thing
good for you and listening to the monday
morning podcast and the bill bert
podcast gets me through the day
if you come out to minnesota anytime
soon i'll be sure to come out and
support you from six feet away go [ __ ]
yourself well that's great
i would love to go out to minnesota i'd
love to
be able to go back out on the road i'm
going to figure it out i can't do it now
because the show would be
outside and it is minnesota it's going
to start getting cold and
i'm not carl eller or jim marshall or
all those great vikings that used to
play outside
um all right here we go cruise ship
stories cruise ship stories what's the
deal
all right cruise ship stories hey bill
i'm your biggest fan from north
africa get out of here that's great i've
been watching your specials and podcasts
for years
i'm from tunisia and i you know it's
funny i could do a show in tunisia right
now in front of the same amount of
people i'm doing in new york city
and i used to work on board cruise ships
luckily i quit before you became a
dictator
dictator and sunk my working place
sunk my working place um nine years of
that [ __ ]
it's an absolute nightmare i dealt with
more complaints
than dr phil and oprah combined but some
of the questions bro
um sometimes i laugh sometimes
i get brain farts sometimes i lose it
here are my top five
most ridiculous encounters i got while i
am working on board a cruise ship
you're right those are the dumbest
people you know what people this is a
great new segment if you want to like
whatever you do if you work in the
public give me your top
five whatever your vocation is dumbest
things people said to you
and i know if somebody's a park ranger
out there in uh
joshua tree they got one question for me
when i asked
one of the park rangers where is the
joshua tree
i thought there was just one i didn't
realize it was a species
um all right number one
top five dumb questions answered asked
on a cruise ship number one
captain made an announcement saying that
tomorrow at 7 00 am
we will cross the equator line oh no
this guy wakes up at 6 a.m takes his
coffee pot and goes to the helipad
and kept looking at the sky oh he didn't
even look into the water he looked into
the sky
7 15 a.m came to 7 50 a.m came
he came to me complaining that he didn't
see the equator line
therefore the captain misinformed him
and demanded the compensation
i almost printed the wikipedia page but
that [ __ ] would get me fired
oh my god i remember when i was a kid i
thought the equator
i just pictured as this big like
almost like uh black rubber tubing that
would have like
fiber optic wire going through that's
how i pictured the equator
um but i was also a kid number two
during a gay
charter cruise one gay complained that
too many gays are hitting on him
and he wants to get off uh we were in
the middle of the ocean
[Laughter]
oh my god i'm so hot people won't leave
me alone god get me off this boat
all right number three oh my god jesus
christ
a bunch of guys who want to [ __ ] other
guys all on there and they're all guys
can you imagine that
guys will [ __ ] anything you stick him on
a [ __ ] boat and you wouldn't
oh my god um number three
second day during the during uh the
crossing from australia to the youth
to the u.s this woman called me saying
there is a penguin
on her balcony i said madam that's
probably because
that's probably a bird because penguins
don't fly
oh boy she started screaming i know a
penguin when i
see one so i sent security
and it was just a seagull uh that night
she came
after dinner asking what happened to the
bird so i tried to be funny and i said
uh
did you like your soup oh god
[Laughter]
she didn't appreciate my joke but her
husband started laughing and of course
she asked for my boss and i got in
trouble
oh wow what a douche i mean talk about
had not have any sense of humor you
thought it was a [ __ ] penguin
you know what do you say was a seagull
was it an osprey number four a woman
came
running saying she saw some black
creatures with
red eyes swimming around the ship
i said uh okay thanks for telling me she
started yelling
ain't you gonna send security to shoot
him oh boy
jesus christ i'm [ __ ] hallucinating
um number five
uh one poor bastard walked inside a
sauna
and found a dude blowing another dude oh
came to me saying he can't forget what
he saw and i should give him a free
drink package
to help him get over it he actually said
package after seeing what he just saw
um i honestly felt for him i told him i
can't do that but i gave him a couple of
bottles of wine after investigating
uh we found out about those gay dudes
turned out one of them was married i
knew it i knew it
and traveling with his wife that happens
a lot uh we asked
what he was doing inside the sauna he
said i was getting a foot massage from a
stranger
wow and then he slowly moved up my leg
yeah i remember one time i uh
i i went to a gym here in new york
and uh they wanted all of this [ __ ]
id and all of this [ __ ] and i was giving
what the
[ __ ] i got this [ __ ] give me the money
blah blah blah i know what happened
somebody ended up talking to the guy and
he said that the other day they had
caught a married dude blowing
uh a gay guy in the sauna
and when he got caught he freaked out
and his wife was out working out
and he said please don't tell my wife
and he i said did you he said yeah i had
to
i was thinking like well you didn't have
to but it i can't
you have to though because he's taking
these risks
and they're probably having unprotected
sex you know this guy's out and about
i mean if he's banging a woman you know
you'd have to do the same thing right i
don't know it's crazy
it's crazy crazy world uh i can write a
book about
this [ __ ] man you should anyway well i
hope
uh you you don't back down your voice
you're the voice of the voiceless in
this pussified world we live in no
i'm not no i'm not every this most
people talk the way i [ __ ] talk
um they just don't do it on tv uh one
more thing bill don't accept that dude's
invitation to saudi arabia you say
the wrong thing about women religions or
kings
or king you're a goner uh we can't
afford to lose one of the last two
comedians who don't give a flying [ __ ]
about triggered folks
that that's you and dave chappelle wow
anytime i get lumped in with the great
dave chappelle that's great peace and
love well thank you um
thank you for my one fan out there in
tunisia
um all right men suck too oh here we go
finally the lady's writing in
hey bill oh it might be a gay dude who
knows hey bill
love the podcast hope you and your
family are doing great i'm a lady
listener and i've been putting together
this email for a while
oh see you see women are smarter guys
are just being little
just send it off she sees [ __ ] you
know like a paralegal here here we go
several months ago i was listening to
one of your old podcasts
where you encourage women to write in
bashing men
in order to even it out yeah all right
cool
so since then i've been writing things
down
that i notice about men that i think are
annoying or funny
oh this is great the list is below
thanks for the laughs and as always go
[ __ ] yourself okay
this is another great one all right
ladies if you want to write in this [ __ ]
this is great and if you have a [ __ ]
job where you deal with the public i
want to hear your top five
dumbest things people said to you all
right
um the way men turn insecurity into
anger
[Laughter]
guilty is charged here example
he [ __ ] up his parking job and is
embarrassed so now he has to rant about
how
cities never make parking spots big
enough for trucks
oh [ __ ] that is totally me except you
said truck i mean i got an old truck but
yeah i [ __ ] about my car because of the
cameras and [ __ ] uh you know it is
embarrassing because i used to be really
good
at parking i speak i used to be great at
backing up
i don't know what it is i cannot use the
backup camera i don't understand it
i can't tell if those yellow lines are
my tires or represent the side
i think it's the side of the car i have
no [ __ ] idea and i always flip up
all right uh we have to call erectile
dysfunction
ed cause men can't bear to hear the
actual words
uh we don't call yeast infections why
eyes
[Laughter]
that's [ __ ] hilarious but not to get
technical just because you have a yeast
infection your [ __ ]
still works right e.d
um erectile dysfunction uh you always
say
women enjoy hooking up two i want to set
the record straight a woman hooking up
with the guy
is like a group of friends deciding to
go to times square for new year's
it seems like it'll be a fun crazy night
but it's really boring and disappointing
and you feel pressured to act like
you're enjoying
yourself the whole time um
well then i i don't know that one i just
feel bad for you you never just had like
a [ __ ] you know
connection sexually with somebody that
didn't lead to a relationship
so you just lay there going oh wow
um that just made me sad the other two
are funny okay well then i wouldn't
you don't sound like some people are
like relationship people so then don't
do that i mean i'm basically a
relationship person
i'm just scared of them all right going
camping
okay going camping they become dictators
of the campsite
have to prove to everyone they know how
to start a fire and set up a tent
yeah i would see that you got to that's
that's some guy [ __ ]
um yeah cause what if what if a bear
comes you know but bear comes i now have
to put that
you behind me like somehow i can fight
off a bear
what i'm really hoping is i i got an
extra couple extra pounds on me so when
he finishes me off he's full
and will leave you alone um not getting
out
of the left lane when there's a line of
cars
behind them because they can't take the
fact that there are people
who want to go faster than them
is this all the same guy
this guy sucks in bed he's a [ __ ] at the
campground i hate those [ __ ] people
i hate those people my only thing i
don't think on the highway is if you
[ __ ]
drive 90 miles an hour and pass me on
the right if i see you coming up on me i
get the [ __ ] out of the way
now the younger me used to try and speed
up and stay in front of you
and break check and do stupid [ __ ] like
that but now i just hey you know looks
like you need to get somewhere
good on you you're going to meet the
cops sooner than i do so they'll be
writing you a ticket so they won't care
that i'm only doing 75.
all right a lot of men consider it a
compliment to tell a girl she's cool
enough to hang with uh to hang with the
guys like
oh [ __ ] really i'm in oh my god if you
say that that's hilarious
um but it is a compliment you know
it is a compliment but that's the exact
and you both you're they're both right
the man is right it is a company you
know you can actually hang out with you
[ __ ] cool that that
is a rare thing but the fact that you
would think to say oh
[ __ ] really am i in that's why you're
cool
because if you said that every guy there
would start laughing
because that's all we do to each other
is what you're doing there is you're
breaking balls
which i don't know about you guys way
i'm wired like that is
the most endearing thing somebody can do
is come up and just start making fun of
me
you know obviously if you're doing it
like from a hateful place i don't enjoy
that it hurts my feelings
but if you're just trashing me like all
this [ __ ] hey billy red balls all of
that [ __ ]
all like oh this guy likes what i do all
right guys act like uh
they're just so much less dramatic than
girls but they just sweep
their interpersonal problems under the
rug and it slowly
and slowly let it erode the friendships
while also talking [ __ ]
to their other friends oh yeah ding ding
ding ding ding you know what if you were
on the family feud right now i don't
even
like whatever you just did one two three
four five i think
you nailed the tops five or six or
whatever
you didn't get answer number 10 yet
you're crushing these
um the way that men don't like don't
know
oh the way that men don't know what's
bothering them
um personally speaking i know what's
bothering me i just don't want to tell
you
because then you're going to be like
well let's talk about it and then i have
to face my feelings
[Laughter]
video games oh i 100 agree with that i
got it
i really have issues with people in
their 30s and 40s
that are still playing video games and
they got like a headset and all of that
dumb [ __ ]
uh i don't know i don't i don't i left
those
wait a minute no no that's not true i
played grand theft auto
in my 30s grand theft auto 3 whenever
the [ __ ] that came out i played that so
much
that i literally i've told this before i
just one day i was like i have to stop
and i went and i unplugged everything
that could be unplugged off my
playstation 2
and just put it in the back of my closet
because i knew
that i'd never be able to figure out how
to plug it back in again because
um oh this is funny i actually got that
playstation 2
from a buddy of mine who was really like
this woman
and he bought her a bunch of nice [ __ ]
and all she got him was like a [ __ ]
hoodie and he got so mad he took her
gifts back and one of them was this
playstation 2.
so then he sold it to me for like 100
bucks so i didn't have the instructions
and what was funny was
like a few months later i ran into the
woman that he liked she was just like
you know you have my playstation 2 right
i was like [ __ ] you talking about
uh when she told me the story anyways
men love mentioning how long it's been
since they cried dude i don't even
remember the last time i cried
uh yeah that's a bad thing that's what
actually kills men
um because we deny
a arguably the biggest healing emotion
there is you got to do it you got to let
it out yeah
guilty of that too i don't know who this
woman is but i'd say you know she knows
guys pretty good
learning to play the guitar a little and
then telling people they play guitar
skateboarding uh
pressing dick against ass and club
well you'd have to have a dick to
understand that uh they get those
why a guy would do that if you had a
dick you'd be doing the same thing uh
they get those tires
that are too big for their truck um
oh the ones that stick out yeah those
guys that are
intentionally uh those guys that
intentionally make their cars louder
what's that about who's that for
um that's for people who love cars
i mean there's certain people that just
want to do i mean you don't think it
sounds cool i think it sounds cool
motorcycles it's so you hear them
because a lot of times you can't see
them it's so you don't hit them
but um i don't know i i understand like
the one i like the muscle car
sound uh like a ballsy truck sound but i
don't like those
uh those ones that they put on the
hondas and stuff
they're that high pitch sounds like a
lawnmower i don't understand those
um or they sound like muted
i don't know all right breaking [ __ ]
while drunk
uh don't know how to buy gifts i'm
guilty of that
they think women can't tell when they're
fake laughing or fake interested
uh they make up 99 of people
oh they make up 99 of people who call
into sports talk radio
uh what the patriots need to do is oh my
god
i [ __ ] hate those shows uh tribal
tattoos
i want to say uh tribal tattoos went out
in the 90s didn't they
that's what i picture when i think of
tribal tattoos well i don't know who you
are man but you [ __ ] crushed it
i was guilty of at least 80 of that
other than video
games and skateboarding i think i was
guilty of all of that
um okay that's the podcast everybody go
[ __ ] yourselves i'll check in on you on
thursday
you know try your hardest to put the
mask
all the way on your face just try if you
can
but anyway as always shout out to
everybody [ __ ] helping people who who
are are too dumb at this point with all
the information out there to avoid the
disease
however if you're in a [ __ ] city like
new york i get it because even if you're
being smart because i feel like i'm
being smart out here but like
you know i don't know the way [ __ ]
people this [ __ ] guy i was just
getting a
a a chicken shwarma wrap and he was just
[ __ ] up on me
he's just he's wearing a mask too but
it's like dude they got it [ __ ]
painted right there stand there i stand
here
same [ __ ] guy who's gonna be bitching
yeah god i mean it's just between
2020 those stupid [ __ ] memes that
people send out those gifts whatever the
[ __ ] you call them
where it's like 2019 at 20 20 and it's
like there's a bird sitting on a thing
and then they show a bird [ __ ] on
your head
and it's like dude you're the bird
[ __ ] on other people's [ __ ] i
don't that's the right analogy you know
what i mean go [ __ ] yourselves i'll talk
to you thursday
you